so
hello to everyone um welcome to the last
day of the conference
uh the session just after lunch so i'm
sure everyone's really sleepy after
their lunch
so to get into the spirit for today i'm
wearing my ndc london badge from last
january
that's kind of helping me remember what
a physical conference is like
uh so just a little bit housekeeping
before we start so um
i like a lot of other people in the uk
at the minute having to do homeschooling
so i'm kind of juggling
um different sessions with my wife so
once i've finished here i do need to go
back
um to help out there so what i want to
ask is if you have any questions
during the talk if you could post them
onto the slack channel
i think we're in track free and just tag
me
in there or if you want to send me
something private do that and then i'll
do my best to try and answer any
questions a little bit later in the
afternoon
so with that today i want to talk about
writing cross-platform games with
monogame in.net which is a bit of a
mouthful
so first of all um just to introduce
myself so my name is stephen haunts
and these days i spend majority of my
time writing and recording content for
pluralsight and skillshare
i've been doing that for about six years
now
but previously before doing kind of what
i do now and in you know the career i've
had in financial services et cetera the
start of my career
um this magazine articles from when i
was 16
it's always had a passion of building
computer games and when i was 16 me and
my friend chris we
bought a game on the amiga 500 this was
called dark commission which was due to
be published
and by a small publisher called gks
design
that was kind of my first foray into the
computer games
world then after that i worked for about
10 years
in companies like argonaut software core
design iodos
criterion studios electronic arts then i
finished up my gaming career at a
small little company called full fats
production so if you've heard of a game
called flick golf
and they're the company that built that
and you know it's one of the so it's
only a very fun time in my life when i
was younger so i worked on lots of
really cool games
it's on the screen there you can see
croc legend of the gobos on the gameboy
color
that was one that was my first ever
published game which was amazing
i did some work on the alien
resurrection game on the playstation
that was my first introduction to
projects that go horribly wrong
because it was very late i think it came
out about 18 months after the film
and i've worked on games like sid
meier's pirates for the psp
down in the bottom right there we've got
sims pets on nintendo ds
and whilst that game wasn't particularly
good i was quite proud of it because we
had
from start football from starting
development to getting the cartridges
made and then onto the shelves we had
nine months
so that was quite a big achievement to
do that and then on the bottom left
there we have a game that was never
sadly released but it was uh black and
white creatures on the nintendo ds
which was an amazing game we'd almost
finished it we were literally three
months away from completion
but the publisher who had the publishing
rights to that game sadly went bust
so it couldn't get released which is a
real shame
so i've worked on lots of um kind of
game production development tools as
well so back when i used to work at
companies like criterion software
who are then bought out by electronic
arts we built a system called runway
studio
now if you think about um platforms like
unity that you have now vendorway studio
was basically like unity but about six
years before
unity ever came out and it was a
commercial development tool so you know
it's
quite a high price tool that we charge
the developers
and it allowed you to kind of build up
all your game assets into a world you
could assign c
plus behaviors to all your different
entities in the game you could link
everything
together with events and kind of build
your game that way
now at the bottom of the screen there
you can see that you had like
connections to different consoles so at
the time gamecube
was the in thing from nintendo as well
as ps2 and the original xbox
so what this let you do is you could
connect to all these different consoles
in real time drag all your assets into
the scene then at the same time on each
of the consoles you can see all the game
being developed
live in front of you it's really quite
cool
anyway fast forward into to now so
last year when was in lockdown so
actually before i say that you know
when i left the games industry i then
went into financial services and got
what my wife calls a proper job
i did that for a bit and worked across
various different kind of enterprise
style businesses um far forward to now
so when was in lockdown last year in
or lockdown v 1.0 as you like to call it
like most people i was kind of you know
struggling with the whole idea of it and
i kind of had this
bright idea that i wanted to to build
something
because the way that i deal with things
like depression and anxiety is i need to
be able to
create something i need something i can
focus my mind on and that's kind of how
i get myself through
difficult periods of time so i wanted to
focus on to on a little problem that i
could solve over time
something that's not work related so
nothing to do with parole site nothing
to do with enterprise development
you know nothing work related no
pressure on it
and then using techniques from like
books like think and grow rich by
napoleon hill
and that book talks about how you kind
of visualize success and what success
looks like so you basically try and
imagine a point in time in the future
where everything's gone well
and then you kind of use that as a way
of sort of mentally preparing yourself
to get
out of a difficult situation so one of
the things that i would mentally
visualize was actually talking at a
conference about
this thing that i built which is kind of
what we're doing now so it kind of feels
like it's coming full circle a bit
but then you know as you're building
something you're kind of
part of my french you study the out
of it you know you spend a lot of time
trying to read up on different subjects
and different libraries and different
development techniques
and it's just a way of being a bit of a
distraction against kind of all the
stuff that's going on
um during the day then the idea was you
just take small steps every day so on a
good day i might get to spend about an
hour just tinkering around with some
code
on another day it might be 10 minutes
but every day you're just trying to move
that needle ever so slightly to actually
produce something
so i decided that i wanted to build a
little game nothing too complex nothing
that i intended to ever release
you know it's not going to be a
commercial product i might intend on
making any money off of it i'm not going
to do any courses or books on it it was
just
a nice little distraction so the first
thing i had to think about was
do i want to use an engine or do i want
to use a framework
because there's two quite distinct
differences between the two
so in modern game development an engine
is something like unity
or godot or godot however you pronounce
it or unreal engine
these are all systems you can download
for free and build games with
the reason why they're called an engine
is because they really do everything for
you so
when you come to building a game in
these systems you're not worrying about
rendering you're not worried about
textures lighting
sound input handling or any of that
that's kind of all done for you you have
the game engine sitting in front of you
so what you're dealing with at that
point is
you know building assets linking
everything together and actually
creating a game
and quite frankly they're brilliant some
of these systems are absolutely
fantastic considering
most of them don't actually cost any
money
but what i wanted to do is kind of
leverage and build up some of the skills
i've got which
my background since leaving the games
industry has all been sort of
net development in c sharp so i kind of
wanted to still play in that pond
but build something a bit more fun you
know i didn't want to do anything
enterprisey
so i started looking at the monogame
framework now the monogame framework
is something that i knew about i've
known about it for years but never
really put much emphasis into it
and the monogame framework is an open
source implementation
of a library that microsoft used to
create called xna
now xna was one of microsoft's early
game development libraries that they
built and it came out kind of around the
time of the xbox 360.
it was a way of encouraging developers
to build indie games that could be sold
on xbox live arcade
but sadly microsoft discontinued it
which is a real shame because it's very
good
and the monogame framework was an open
source implementation built by
enthusiasts to try and replicate the
features
of xna and really it's kind of taken off
you know it's got an entire life of its
own many commercial games are built with
it
so one that people are probably familiar
with is stardew valley which is probably
one of the most famous ones
which is a you know kind of a very cute
cartoony farming simulator
that's available on you know pc mac and
even games consoles
so the good thing with xna is if you and
pre-compile all of your code you can
actually run it on
like nintendo switch consoles for
example
so when you look at a game framework
like xna um it doesn't really do a lot
um when i started building this engine i
started thinking i said well do i want
to worry about 3d or 2d and i didn't
really want to worry about 3d
because xna and monogame does do 3d but
you have to do
a hell of a lot of work to do it it's
very complicated and i just didn't want
to give myself that kind of mental
stress i thought well i'll stick to 2d
because 2d games are fun it's really
something like monogame gives you some
very basic features it gives you a basic
maths library
it gives you the ability to play sound
effects and music you've got input
handlers so for the keyboard
a games controller and a mouse gives you
a basic asset pipeline which i'll talk
about in a moment
and it gives you the ability to
rasterize graphics onto the screen so if
you have a sprite of a character you
just want to
splat it on the screen it allows you to
do that
it doesn't really do a huge amount more
than that to be honest so you have to
build
some functionality on top of that to
actually be able to build a game
so you had to build your own engine so
the things i had to look at was game
state and scene management
and some basic ui controls a messaging
system so the different assets in the
game can actually talk to each other
uh font rendering just so you can like
you know show like high scores and
menus sprites and animation some
collision detection
and a scene graph so scene graph is
basically like a directed graph of nodes
where you might have different sprites
all linking together
to build a scene on the screen
so monogame is straightforward to
install so you can go to the monogame
website
and you can download a package to
install so i use the mac
and that's just kind of what i prefer
but it works on mac and windows
just you know it works fine across both
install the installer then that gives
you a series of templates when you do
your file new solution
which is quite cool
now the code that i've built i've open
sourced it i'll just put it out for free
and i've tried to make it as tidy and
neat as possible and include lots of
tutorials
so that it's actually kind of easy to
pick up so if anyone does want to take a
look
at it it's at github.com stephen horne
xo game 2d which is a funny little name
i just gave the engine because
obviously you have to think about
branding first
now what i want to do during this talk
is i've kind of got two versions of this
talk i've got the version that i do
uh to user groups and that lasts nearly
two hours
which is kind of spending a lot of time
diving through code but we only have an
hour so what i want to do is focus on
some of the patterns that i've used to
build some of these games using monogame
and so i'm not doing a direct code code
walkthrough but then what we'll do is at
the end if we've got a bit of time we'll
kind of
dive into visual studio and i'll show
you where everything is and kind of show
you how it works
now when you look at it in github for
example so you've got
a whole series of tutorials that i've
started writing and i'm going to write a
load more and intentionally to write a
few blog posts around it as well so the
tutorials take you through things like
you know how to render a blank screen
how to draw a sprite how to move the
sprite
how to track and use the mouse how to do
some font rendering and how to do
collision detection
and i've got a whole list of other
tutorials i want to add as well
so when you load up the solution um
you're presented with
um well the top level solution folder is
called engine it's a project enabled xo
game 2d and that's kind of where all the
heavy lifting of the engine
lives it's stuff that you know if you're
interested you can dive in and have a
look at or
it's stuff that you can just use without
necessarily getting into the details
which is quite cool
and during lockdown i built two little
projects
just for a bit of fun so the first one
at the top there is i built a little
recreation of nintendo's duck hunt
so if anyone old enough remembers the
original nintendo nes console
or the famicom i think it's called in
america then i had a game called duck
hunt you played with a little light gun
and you could shoot these
cute little ducks and so i did a little
recreation of that and i also did a
fun recreation of conway's game of life
and
i did that kind of as a tribute to
mr conway who sadly passed away last
year which was quite sad so i did a
little
tribute to that
so just got a video that i'll show you
here first
[Music]
so what you can see here is doug itself
i apologize for music
[Music]
okay turn that down so the premise is
quite simple
you just shoot these little ducks as you
shoot the ducks you've got a little
bullet counter at the bottom
and then you've got a little black
counter there as well and then a high
score at the top
so this kind of tweakers quite a lot of
different techniques into the engine so
you've got collision detection
we've got sending messages between
different events so as you shoot the gun
the gun sends out an event if it detects
a collision with a duck
it plays the death animation and the
deficit defense
and then sends a message to the high
score and sends a message to the counter
at the bottom
and then at the end of the level when
you run out of ducks it sends a message
to this little marquee that scrolls down
it's all very sort of message and event
based
so the second project that i built was
conway's game of life i'll show you a
little demo of this
now it's like a little paint package you
just
draw on the screen
and then when you run the simulation it
runs a game of life simulation but what
i did is added an extra little
uh rule to it so as each cell
so for every each generation of the cell
i slowly fade the colors out and they
slowly die over time and it kind of
gives it that nice kind of fading out
technique
which looks quite cool
that is one place if you if you draw a
straight line
and then let it run actually creates
this quite a nice pattern which i
thought was quite cool
yeah anyway so let's go to the next bit
so
starting out with monogame the first
thing you want to do is or
when you build anything you want to
start out with that library's equivalent
of hello world
now the way you set up a program in
monogame is very straightforward
so everything kind of runs through a
static main
method you set up the game loop function
which is a monogame
class and you call run on that method
then what you do is you have a class
that derives from gaming
so the main the main class is called
game and then we create our own instance
on top of that
instantiation on top of that so in the
constructor here we set the
or we initialize the engine so in this
case we're saying we want a
1080p play service we set the mouse to
visible
we then have a method that's overridden
where you can load your content
and then we have two methods we have
update and draw so update is where you
would ordinarily update your game logic
and any physics and ai that might run in
the game in this case we're just
checking for some button presses so
escape
closes the game and f1 sorry f switches
between full screen
and then you do your actual rendering in
the draw method so in this case we're
just
clearing and setting the color to blue
for the background color
that's kind of the the easiest type of
application you can write
again i'll try and demo this at the end
and actually look through code properly
in this instance here so we've got the
load content method
uh so we're loading up a logo
so you see we've got load content then
we've got an asset called exo engine
logo
and then in our draw method at the
bottom we do engine.begin render and
then we can just render that scene
to the screen so a scene is kind of like
a
you know a directed graph of objects
that you can build so as you add
different objects to the scene they'll
get added to the render list
so you're not rendering individual
sprites explicitly you add them to the
scene and then you say to render the
scene
so monogamy comes with something called
an asset pipeline
so typically when you write a game you
want to get assets into the game so
assets will be things like textures and
sprites
sound effects and music and fonts as
well
but typically when you have an asset
like this you need to convert it into a
format that's going to be usable by the
game engine
so xna provides a simple tool called the
monogame pipeline tool
so here we you know on the left in the
project you can see we've got the assets
for
the duck attack game so we load all
those in
you can then compile all those assets
into an asset file which then gets
included in your projects
then when you go to load um say the
crosshair.png
you refer to it by name so you just say
you know load the asset crosshair and
that will load that into the game
so managing assets is pretty
straightforward
now the way a game like this works is
you have a very tight
uh game loop and it just runs as fast as
it can
and as you saw in the little snippet of
code earlier what we're trying to do is
we're trying to separate all of our
scene updating from our rendering so
those two things happen differently so
if you're updating positions or
velocities on a sprites that will happen
in the update method
then all the render method does is it's
just concerned with just getting stuff
onto the screen
as fast as it can and effectively from
that
your game is just one big giant state
machine it's a massive finite state
machine
so you could have a game state which is
like you know main menu
game level def screen and then you just
switch between different states and then
as you go and call render it checks what
state is in it just renders the
appropriate scene
you want that to run as fast as it can
in a loop
you know you're trying to achieve at
least 60 frames a second if not more
so what this means then is when you do
things like async so when you do a game
in uh mono game you don't really have
things like async and awaits so you're
not letting
nets handle all of the asynchronous
stuff for you
because that's not really what you want
what you want is a loop that runs as
fast as it can and then you work out
you kind of budget how you're going to
use your 60 frames a second as best you
can
so one thing that i had to deal with
when i started building the engine was
something called view projection scaling
so when going full screen so if you
imagine you've got a game you run in a
window like the demo you saw
typically you're gonna run a game in a
full screen mode
so when you initiate full screen there's
going to be a request down to the
graphics driver and it's going to try
and get the
whatever render surface the graphic
driver tells it to use so i'm presenting
on an imac in a minute it's going to be
like 5000 pixels by
something ungodly
you could be running on something that
has a native resolution of 1080p
or you could be running on a system as a
4k screen
or if you're using a macro you might
have a 6k screen for example
now that makes it quite difficult when
you're trying to actually render stuff
in certain positions on the screen
so if you remember back in the original
snippet of code we showed we set up an
initial game window of 1080p
now if i get that 1080p window and tell
it to go full screen
if it starts switching the coordinate
system that you're using saying that's
much higher resolution it's going to
kind of make your
assets kind of explode all over the
screen a bit like a bit of bad written
css
so what you want to do is you want to
have this kind of like
virtual resolution of 1080p where you
place your sprites and then have the
game engine kind of work out where
that's actually going to be on the
physical screen and that's called view
projection scaling
and one again by itself doesn't do that
for you which is a bit of a pain in the
bottom
so you have to write some complex code
to do it now this is actually the
hardest part of the engine
getting this bit right so i had to kind
of rely on a lot of
old legacy github repos and a really old
book about xla to work out how to do
this properly
to make it kind of seamless finish
instance here you know we've got the
1080p screen and that's actually being
rendered to but that's actually been
projected onto a screen that's 5120 by
2880 pixels
but the game doesn't care what the final
native resolution is he just wants to
know if i put something at 50 50 on the
x50 y50 on the screen is it going to
appear in the same position when you go
full screen
so i took a bit of a bit of doing
now the next bit i had to deal with was
sprites and rendering sprites
so a sprite is effectively just an array
of pixel data so it's rgb values
or rgb alpha values because if you use a
png then you can have a transparency
layer so you can actually have your
sprites be see-through which is kind of
desirable
so those sprites go through the image
asset pipeline
so the little tool that i showed before
and you can load it into a
sprite object in monogame then you can
just tell it to render to the screen
which is nice and simple
so some of the examples of sprites we've
got in the duck attack game so we've got
some different sprite animations
of the sort of the duck flying there's
like three or four frames of it flying
we've got the crosshair that you use to
shoot the ducks we've got the death
animation so when you shoot the duck it
kind of goes into this kind of weird
flashy animation and it kind of dives to
the bottom of the screen
then we've got the bullets and the
little duck registers at the bottom so
they're all sprites
the game is kind of boring unless you
haven't uh unless you have animation
so why then i had to write it was an
extension that sits on top of my sprite
class
which allows you to do very basic
animation so the way or the
techniques i had was linear
interpolation and ping pong
so linear just means if you've got three
frames one two and three it will
literally just go
render frame one then two then three one
and two then three and so on
whereas ping pong it will go render one
two three two
one two three and that's kind of what
helps you get that kind of
interesting flapping effect on the bird
so another one of the things you need to
worry about is input management which
thankfully is one of the
easiest parts of xna so it supports um
game controllers so i tested it with a
or some of the things i've played with
i'll test it with a ps4 controller works
perfectly fine
and so mouse and keyboard as well
so this particular game uses the mouse
tracking of the x and y for the
crosshair
uses the left mouse button for shooting
if you want to go to full screen you hit
the f key and it toggles to full screen
and then escape just takes you back to
the main menu
so another thing that's quite important
i had to build
was collision detection
so the fun kind of really comes from the
objects and they start interacting with
each other
if you can't have objects interacting
then you don't really have a game
but collision detection can be
computationally expensive
there's kind of a lot of iterating of
loops and arrays that has to go on
behind the scenes so therefore there's
you can cheat there's a few ways in
which you can cheat
so you've got bounding box collision and
pixel perfect collision
so bounding box collision is where you
literally have a box drawn around the
sprites which you know starts from zero
zero sprite coordinate and then goes to
the maximum width of the x and the y
that's right then you've got the same
for the
little crosshair as well so if each of
those two boxes intersects then you
class it as a collision
so that's a good cheap way of getting
collision but it can be quite inaccurate
because if you
you see that duck in the middle there if
you move the the crosshair
to below where the duck's head is i mean
it says it's a collision but actually
it's not i mean those two objects aren't
actually touching
so what you can do then is you can cheat
and you can use
a combination of pixel perfect collision
which is where
pixel perfect collisions if you have an
actual pixel of one sprite physically
touching a pixel of another
sprite then you class that as a
collision that's quite expensive to do
is he's got lots of iterating through
arrays so what you do is you cheat and
you use bounding box collision first you
say is there an intersection between
those two bounding boxes
if there is you then switch to pixel
perfect collision
because you don't want to be doing pixel
perfect collision between all of the
assets all the time because it'll be
quite slow and inefficient
so you're just waiting to have a
bounding box in section and then you
switch to pixel perfect collision
which is kind of a good way of cheating
it
okay so the next bit that we looked at
was scene management
i mentioned this a little bit before but
a scene management is a bit like a room
and a room has objects in it and those
objects can move about they can interact
with each other
and as we'll see later you can actually
send messages between the different
objects in the room
so the room is a bit like a directed
graph so you've got a node at the top
which is the room then you can add
sprites into it you can add sound
effects into it
and then what you do is you add that
scene to the render list and then you
say you render this scene so you're not
saying
render this duck render this duck render
this crosshair you just say you render
the scene
anything that's been added to the scene
will get drawn at that point
so the way i handle scene management in
in the engine is i have
various different uh render layers so
i've got five set up by default
so anything that's in render layer one
gets rendered first
then anything that's in render layer 2
gets rendered seconds
and so on so what this means is that if
you render everything in render layer 1
first
that will get rendered and then anything
in render layer 2 will get rendered over
the top of it so if you have to have
things drawn in a specific order like a
zed order
and this basically lets you control that
quite easily so the background's always
at the back
then you have the ducks then you have
the scoreboard and the duck counters and
bullet counters
so if the duck flies behind the
scoreboard you don't want it to appear
in front of the scoreboard and it's
appear behind it
and then you've got the crosshair which
goes over all of that and then we had
that billboard animation so when it said
level two and it kind of scrolled down
saying level two that was in the top
most layer
so really what you're doing is you're
getting a kind of a pseudo 3d
representation of the scene as a render
order
it's a bit like when you're in
powerpoint and you know a box appears
in the wrong layers you have to right
click on it and say center back or you
know send back a layer it's the same
concept as that
and what we do is around the whole scene
system we have what's called a collision
manager
so the collision manager is what will
look at everything that's in the scene
and it will try and work out if any of
those objects are colliding
within that scene
so if i've got the crosshair for example
when i run the
the logic for the crosshair i can say oh
you know are you colliding with anything
in this scene it will come back and give
you a list and say yes i'm actually
colliding with this duck here
so when you press the button and you
send out the you know the gunshot
message
you can then easily work out that the
crosshair is interacting with that duck
so we then want to send a message to the
sound manager and say play the gun sound
effect
and then we send a message to the duck
and we say okay well if you've been hit
switch to the
duck um duck shot state and then the
duck death state where it kind of moves
falls down the screen
and all of that is kind of being
executed
in that tight loop at 60 frames a second
hopefully
you know everything's going as fast as
it can so we go into our draw method it
goes okay
layer one render that scene layer two
render everything there layer three
render that and then so on but as he's
doing that he's calling the updates
method on each of these different
objects that are in the scene
so the next thing we've got then is
entity messaging
so each asset in the scene doesn't know
anything about any other asset
i mean you could kind of hard code it
it's all kind of global so that you know
that the crosshair can
know about a duck in the code i mean you
could do it that way
but you really want to decouple
everything so that each game entity is
actually anonymous so it's a bit like
microservices running in a container
now at this point we don't want to go
full enterprise but you know as you're
all at a
professional software development
conference i suppose we kind of need to
work mention the word enterprise
somewhere so that you can
prove to your employers that you're
getting value
but the concepts are kind of similar to
how you do it you know messaging through
something like rabbitmq
it's kind of a similar process or
similar concepts but kind of
simplified
so what we do is we have a channel
system in the engine that are built
it's very very simple so you can add a
new channel
so you might have a channel called duck
hit and then you can send messages
to one of those channels so the
crosshair could work out that it's
actually intersected with the duck and
it could send a message to the duck hit
channel
and each duck is monitoring those
channels
for a message about its own instance and
it can then interact
and do something at that point so it's a
good way of
decoupling all of the objects in the
game now going back to what i'm saying
about renderware studio that i worked on
many years ago and
engines like unreal engine a lot of
these work in the same way it's all
about
sending messages between different
entities and then having the entities
themselves work out what to do when they
receive that message
so it's kind of the similar similar
principle
so in this case we've got the crosshair
that can send out a duck hit message
when the duck receives the duck hit
message it knows to play the flashing
animation
it might do that for so many seconds and
then it'll switch to its death state
which will give you that little dropping
animation it plays a little penny
whistle sound
once that goes off screen it basically
then destroys its own instance
at the same time we have a gun trigger
sound effect going to the sound effects
manager at that point it plays the nice
m60 kind of gunshot sound
so i'm pretty sure all farmers when they
go that continues in m60
when a duck receives its message you
know as well as doing its um
sort of death sequence it might send a
message to the scoreboard and say
i've been legitimately hit by a bullet
sends 10 points
and then the scoreboard automatically
adjusts
a duct hit message can go to the bullet
counter so it knows to deduct a bullet
and the same with the actual duct
counter for the level so it knows the
duct's been shot if it's been
legitimately shot it turns blue if the
duck escapes and flies off the screen
then it turns red
so techniques like this just make it
really easy to wire up all your
different entities so the code for the
dark and the code for the sound effect
manager they're all very self-contained
they don't know about anything else
outside of their own bit of code
but then it makes it really easy to tie
everything together with these very
simple messages
i said the uh the channel system is very
very basic at the minute so there's no
concept of a return
at the moment and so if uh if you want
to have
one entity send a message to the other
and then that send a return message
it kind of doesn't support that directly
you're going to have to clutch it a bit
so one of the upgrades i want to do is
to add an automatic return or rtx
channel
into a message um i need some kind of
concept of message orderings i've not
built that in yet
those are having correlation ids and
batching kind of the things you'd expect
from like you know rabbit enqueue or
any of the other queuing systems that
are out there but i didn't really need
it for this game so i haven't built it
yet
okay so some of the future goals i want
to build with this
and so i want to really build a game
that's a replica of um horison's skin i
don't know if anyone
is old enough to remember that it's a
very popular game on the zx spectrum
if you guys like character horus and you
can go to the ski shop and you can buy
your skis and you have to go through the
slalom run
if you get to the bottom without
crashing you then win money to then go
back to the ski shop
so a very very fun game
another game i want to build um i think
this was more popular in america
than over in the uk or europe but it's a
game called number munchers it's an
educational game
for teaching uh basic math concepts to
kids
so i think this could be actually quite
a fun little thing to build
just to help my son be there learning
his multiple multiplications
that's a little game that i'm planning
to build
and something else i really want to do
is kind of a cross between
uh something like oregon trail and a
text adventure
so you can probably tell that i'm really
into into old retro games i still think
they're better than a lot of the games
that come out these days
just because they force you to use your
imagination
but i've always loved the concept behind
oregon trail especially if you've played
ever played the original
and if you've not heard of it it's
effectively just a resource management
game but it's
really good fun and another one i wanted
to look at was
a kind of uh speed board people too
so uh it's not really football it's kind
of
more like a fatal frisbee i guess it's a
good way of describing it
but that'd be a good little sort of fun
game to build in this engine as well so
you've got like a scrolling
uh stadium that you're playing in lots
of different characters that you can
control so i think that'd be quite good
fun
there's some final thoughts before i
sort of switch over to visual studio and
just give you a little tour demo so
the whole reason this project existed
was a way of trying to cope with um
lockdown last year it's ironic as i say
this because uk is in lockdown as we
speak
so kind of the similar but it doesn't
quite feel as bad this time around
mainly because the schools are a bit
more organized
but at the time i needed something just
to focus on just to take my mind away
from
a lot of the other stuff that was going
on and this was the project that did
that
it's kind of something i recommend
everyone should do is try and just take
on some kind of little creative project
that's completely
disconnected from what you might do at
work you know don't give yourself any
kind of pressure over it
some days i'd spend an hour on this
engine some days i'd spend
10 minutes some days i just wouldn't
even touch it at all but you always try
and just move that needle ever so
slightly
and kind of build something for yourself
which is kind of where this project came
from
yeah so the concept is you know still
code for fun you know a lot of us spend
a lot of time doing
enterprise stuff solving the same
problems time and time again
you know now i've been kind of in this
industry for several decades now you
kind of see the same problems and same
things getting recycled
just through different technologies and
it kind of gets a bit boring after a
while so it's always
good to remember to have some fun with
what you do with your chosen craft
so that's the main part of the talk so
how we doing we've kind of
finished quite early so what i'm going
to try and do is switch over to visual
studio
i just got to github first so i'm
presuming everyone can still see the
screens it says i'm still sharing
oops
okay please don't sign me up okay exit
game 2d
okay so if you go into the github
project um i've tried to make this kind
of reasonably presentable
in here so if anyone does want to play
around with any of the code then
it should be fairly easy to get up and
going
so the best place to start when you load
the solution is to go into these
tutorial folders
i do i've got a list of about 15 total
tutorials i want to write i just haven't
got one finishing them yet
but we start off with things like you
know a blank screen drawing a sprite
moving a sprite around a screen then
getting it to track the mouse
rendering fonts and then collision
detection
and then we've got the actual engine
itself in xo game
2d or exo game engine this is kind of
where the guts of everything
is that i've had to rend i've had to
work on
and then we've got the conway's game of
life code in here this is quite a small
example it's not too complex
and then we have the duck attack code
itself
so in here you can see we've got all the
different game states they've got the
main menu
the playing game for example
so you as you get to shuffle so shuffle
saw the word shuffle there just read it
out
as you get to look through some of the
code you can just kind of see how things
are wired up
so here you can see you know we're
adding all of the different sprites into
the scene
we're setting up different channels for
the score the duck kit and the gun fired
you know initializing the billboard
so hopefully it's fairly straightforward
to go through
so i loaded up visual studio
i'll try to kind of put everything neat
into different folders
so a lot of the renderers that are
supported by the game are in this
renderers folder so we've got animated
sprites
this is where you can just literally
load load a frame texture and add it
into an array
and then you can basically tell it to
you know switch to the next frame which
is iterates a frame counter
and then depending on whether you're
doing linear or ping pong animation
it'll automatically work out what frame
um needs to be played then you can just
auto increment the frames
um or whatever speed you want so if you
want to
increment it a frame per second or you
know increment it
one frame at a time as it renders
through the game loop obviously you're
going to get the animation playing very
very fast you need to kind of think
about the speed
you want to play the animation
got a class in here which actually stole
actually still it's open source i
borrowed from somewhere else which i've
sort of referenced here so a guy called
john mcdonald and gary texmo
i've got some code here for drawing
things like circles
and arcs field rectangles which is kind
of what i use for the user interface
library
and their code was originally written
for xna so
the code is quite the code is quite old
but because xna
and monogamer virtually identical it
didn't really take much effort to get it
working in here
but if you're wanting to draw some user
interface elements like buttons
or drawing like a heads-up display and
you just wanted to do like a big
rectangle for example you can just use
this library
which is quite good
and then we have the the basic sprite
code
which is where you can load up different
assets or graphics from the
asset pipeline you've got a way of doing
uh collision so if if this sprite
instance for example was a duck and
you've got another sprite which is the
crosshair you can pass one into the
other and so you do want collide
it'll give you a pixel perfect um
response of whether it collides or not
so i'm hoping a lot of this stuff will
actually be quite straightforward to
work through and
say the good thing is because it well i
don't know if you see this is a good
thing or not because it doesn't use
async and wait and you basically start
off with a main loop
it's very easy to follow through so you
kind of find main and then you just
debug through it at that point you
haven't got any kind of weird async
stuff going off and doing things in the
background and then returning it's all
kind of very linear
which is quite useful
so that's kind of really what i wanted
to show you it's a fairly short talk
but if you are interested in doing 2d
game developments
in net and you're kind of wanting
something that you can play with to get
you started
then you can go ahead and use this
engine it's hopefully fairly
straightforward to use
the code's all mit licensed so
you can kind of do what you want with it
um
yeah that's pretty much it apart from
saying that if you are
obviously struggling with things like
lockdown you you know you do want to
kind of keep your mind active so i
really do recommend
just working on something non-work
related so where the pressure's
completely off just to give you
something to focus on which is quite
cool this is this was kind of my little
lockdown project
um early last year and it kind of helped
me get through
some of the monotony of homeschooling
and being stuck in the house
okay so with that thank you thank you
very much for coming along and
i appreciate for everyone you know
watching lots of talks that are online
and not face to face is
is hard and it's quite it can be quite
tiring especially if you've been doing
workshops as well so imagine you've done
two days of workshops and three days of
talks which is
quite hardcore but congratulations for
getting the end of the conference
hopefully at some point this year or
maybe early next year we can all start
getting back into a room
with each other and actually sort of
doing traditional conferences which will
be quite fun
so again if you have any questions if
you can drop them in slack
in channel or track three i believe
we're in if you could tag me in them as
well just in case i can't get to them
straight away so
i need to go back and do a maths lesson
uh but yeah if you have any questions
let me know and i'll do my best to try
and answer them in slack i believe the
slack team will be open for a few days
after the conference so
you should still have access to all of
that so with that thank you very much
and enjoy the rest of your conference
thank you